[Music]
so the keystone xl pipeline was slated
to create
11 000 good paying jobs now it will
create precisely zero joe biden killed
it in his first week in office but there
is some good news
and that news comes from john kerry he's
now the white house's global warming
whisperer
he flies around on a private jet to
better understand the enemy
john kerry's message is simple all the
people are out of work actually have an
alternative
they can go build solar panels in china
what president biden wants to do is make
sure those
folks have better choices that they have
alternatives
they can be the people who go to work to
make the solar panels
they were making them here at home
celina zito is a reporter at the
washington examiner and a columnist at
the new york post and we're happy to
have veronica
thanks so much for coming on there's
something about that clip that
really no matter how you feel about
fossil fuels is infuriating the
high-handedness with which he dismisses
adults americans jobs i mean what do you
make of that
well it's incredibly insulting to tell
someone they're going to have a better
job
what's the description of better better
paying
i don't think so solar panel technician
jobs
um are are notoriously sometimes three
four times less than what you would make
on the keystone
pipeline and they're also jobs that will
uproot them from their communities and
their families
these are um aspects that are very
important to
these workers that they're very because
they're very connected to their
community
i notice there's sort of a built-in bias
among our leaders against traditionally
masculine jobs and in favor of kind of
neutered sad davos type jobs i mean do
you see a threat in this at all
well it the problem i see is a problem
that
that people that make these decisions
are people that more likely than not
haven't worked with their hands
and they don't quite understand the
satisfaction of doing that
and they don't understand why you would
even want to do that
but you know i would argue if you're
going to impact someone's life
why don't you go to where they live and
look them in the eye or maybe do what
they do and understand
why it's important to them and why
that's part of their identity
right you've covered the news for a
while how many times have we heard
whatever they're taking away is going to
be replaced by something better didn't
they say that
nafta trying to join the w2a we we're
going to retrain you for something
better how'd that work
so what this really reminds me of is
what happened
around in my area in western
pennsylvania eastern ohio 1977 it was
known as black monday
where thousands of people lost their job
in all in one day
in one industry but what they didn't
take account for
was that the barber shops the hotels the
schools the school districts
and and and president carter at that
time refused to meet
with those um union workers who went
down and asked him to listen to them
and help them about their jobs it's the
same thing we're seeing here
and what they got was broken families
and heroin it's just so sad oh it's
crushing
uh salinasito i appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you thanks for having me
so